bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france d'abord est-ce que
l'annoncent d'un premier vaccin russe
vous étonne
oui elle a été menée absolument tout le
monde a tout à fait clairement et la
raison c'est que on ne pensait pas que
la russie était aussi dense et rejoignez
le club très fermé de trois pays qui
voulait produire à être les premiers à
produire pour l'ensemble de l'humanité
levac ça donc c'est très intéressant
les réactions hosni a sont aussi
intéressantes mais sur le plan
géopolitique
ça montre une arrivée à delà de la
russie dans ce jeu qui est très
important à la fois son plan sanitaire
mais aussi sur le plan sur le plan
économique et donc c'est c'est important
moi j'étais très très très frappé par le
fait de la russie on sait être capable
de fabriquer un milliard de doses de
vaccins c'est parce que le vrai problème
aujourd'hui tout le monde parle des
procédures de est celle où il faut faire
ces procédures et je ne sais pas si
c'est pas mal aurez vous parle l'avenir
le gras à ce qu'a dit le président
poutine
mais le plus difficile c'est
l'industrialisation parce que faire un
vaccin pourra instant volontaire mais
volontaire c'est facile mais en faire un
milliard c'est beaucoup plus difficile
est ici à aurait passé donc hors tout
cas un accord par exemple avec un état
au brésil justement pour ensuite
produire sur place
ce vaccin russe oui sauf que le
président j'ai bien écouté votre
reportage c'est ça en 2021
dans un nom à peu près et donc leur
président poutine a bien dit que le
vaccin est de commencer à être produit à
la fin de cette année donc ce qui veut
dire que la russie pense avoir les
moyens de faire ça c'est nouveau et ça
change un petit peu la donne par rapport
aux anglais américains et aux chinois
qu'ils pensaient avoir en gros à
l'exclusivité de la production
industrielle de de ce bal ça encore
faut-il oms appelle à la prudence un
vis-à-vis de ce vaccin russe qui est
sous le feu des critiques
est-ce que c'est par exemple si sanofi
l'union européenne avait fait ça cette
annonce est ce que les réactions étaient
les mêmes qu'en pensez vous la france a
fait d'accord avec l'action il ya à peu
près deux mois
à l'époque il n'y avait aucune
publication des anglais cette question a
été faite en juillet donc il ya un petit
peu de poids deux mesures c'est à dire
ce qui paraissait logique normale pour
glaxo pareil tout à fait anormal et
entendu c'est vrai qu'il faudra que les
russes publient leurs résultats pour que
tout le monde puisse évaluer puis
surtout il faut qu'il respecte les
procédures difficile et contraignant
d'homologation mais j'espère que ils
vont le faire il n'y a pas de raison
qu'il ne le fasse pas la mise en
circulation du vaccin russin prévu pour
janvier 2021 il y aura d'autres vaccins
qui vont suivre sur le marché
durant l'année prochaine ce qui a été
annoncé à ma connaissance c'est le
vaccin britannique avec avec glaxo avec
des précommandes française et l'union
européenne
sanofi en fait c'est à ceux ci à glace
où il n'y a pas vraiment de vaccins le
français puisque pasteur et un étang est
en retard
et puis le vaccin de loin derna des
états unis pour le chinois
c'est un peu comme pour pour les rues ça
a été annoncé il ya quelques semaines
que c'était testé dans l'armée chinoise
il n'y a pas eu de deux polémiques sur
ce vaccin chinois qui n'a pas été non
plus publiés plus que le français en
fait c'est pas vrai il a été hué choses
qui ont été publiés la semaine dernière
c'est à l'époque il n'y a pas eu ces
protestations alors il faut normalement
10 ans pour les périodes d'essai là le
dantec a été raccourcie injustement pour
lutter contre à la coved 19 quelle
conséquence à votre avis sur
l'efficacité du vaccin
moi ça me fait penser c'est que ya pas
eu de très gros moyens qui est émis
jusqu'à présent sur la vaccination
à part ce celui sur le strass à ce qui
veut dire que si vraiment on veut faire
les essais rapides et de monter des des
vaccins rapidement on peut le faire et
le reste un petit peu des mauvaises
excuses
il n'y a pas eu assez d'argent mais sur
la malaria parle assez d'argent mis sur
la dengue ou sur d'autres vaccins en
plus y'a les nouvelles méthodes
maintenant plus efficaces plus rapides
alors et donc ça devient l'homme
industrielle et un problème aussi
géopolitique prend une géopolitique et
des enjeux aussi économique autour de ce
fameux vaccin pour lutter contre le
corps d'un virus oui il ya des et
entendu économique s'était rappelée dans
votre reportage précédent mais aussi
véritablement géopolitique j'ai bien
noté
elle était la liste des pays qui avaient
fait des accords avec la russie s'est
pas exactement les mêmes que ceux qui
ont fait d accord avec avec glaxo donc
il ya on a un peu l'impression qu'il ya
un côté les russes et les chinois qui
s'intéressent à l'afrique ont pays en
voie de développement
ah et puis l'autre côté il ya les autres
laboratoires classique qui s'intéresse à
l'europe et aux etats unis
merci à vous philippe froguel âge
rappelle que vous êtes un chercheur
professeur à l'impérial college de
londres à l'université à lille deux feux